but what would you what would you what
would I suggest to something okay for
the 11 years that I've been Muslim
trying to get married not being able to
get married been actively pursuing it
what would you have suggested a woman
like that does stuff no like I think a
secure man can handle that oh she has a
career uh she can't be feminine exactly
I don't think people yeah I don't think
men necessarily think like that but nor
are we having a discussion that entails
sisters can't have a career and then
across that way I'm listening to you
guys yeah so just clarifying personally
in my circle of friends and this is
amongst practicing sisters not so
practicing sisters
um anybody who is married has a good
husband he earns not even loads of money
but just enough to pay for everything
they need she doesn't want to work she's
happy bro she is happy we're not talking
about what you're talking about we're
talking about this set of girls he has
these boss babes these feminists let me
ask the questions come from where do you
think they come from
what I Hoover the house yes wash the
dishes yes
um I don't know whatever you want okay
no no no no let me finish yeah I will do
that if I want to
I wish I could find men that actually
thought like that because to be honest
the majority of men want women to work
today
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and a child American reward click
the link and donate what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to the bitter truth show where
we're here we're talking about truths
about what kind of truths bitter truth
the bitter ones that you don't like but
it's the truth uh wrong sisters if you
want to be on the panel be your sisters
or brothers and by the way we are open
to anybody's final life even if you're
non-muslim even if you're wearing a
hijab or not you know as long as you
know
um everyone's covered this in it but for
men and women of course so you can apply
because some people like oh you know do
I have to look like this or whatever so
you can apply for the panel if you have
questions in the CIA base I'm going
through this in my marriage or I'm a
single brother or a sister looking to
get married or whatever it may be you
can send those questions in we can give
you something to see inshallah from the
sisters and the brothers and yes so
let's get straight into the topic the
topic today is to the brothers would you
want a career wife
um I obviously I'm not married so I I
don't know what marriage is like or
anything but I don't think I'd want one
because of
um how Society is nowadays with like
movies and uh basically the media
um I know that whenever we have a kid
she's she's not gonna have to but I I
think that for the sake of the kids
it'll be better if she's part-time or
not working because then she can fully
focus on bringing up the kid in the
Islamic and correct way and that that
would protect
um the child's future and then hence
obviously our future
thinking ahead mashallah Brothers like
you deserve two wives
that face will go foreign
no orientation is not a problem bro you
can career orientated no problem the
problem here is that you want to pursue
your career be a doctor be it I don't
know focused on Career that's what
career oriented yeah as in Korea once a
career wants to work
do you mean she's uh not giving up
everything else but she's 100 on right
I'm focusing completely on my career
yeah
listen I am going to work that's what
yeah yeah I know but like everything
else is yeah yeah you know I understand
but everybody everything else in her
life is um the secondary she won't think
about it so you get a lot of women who
what that's the woman loves you kids but
she wants to work well because
personally I think the issue and
obviously you know I'm I'm a little bit
young I need to build up my opinions and
stuff but when uh you you see a lot of
women who get to mid 30s 40s
they haven't thought about marriage yet
like they haven't even begun looking and
it takes a while so I um if that what
you mean by career women then my
previous answer stays exactly let me um
make you very clear me myself I would
not want a career woman I would not want
a career wife I wouldn't want a wife
who's like okay yeah
um now you're gonna look after the kids
I'm gonna have to go because I'm a
doctor I'm not gonna let go of this
because I studied five years to become
it hey why because I want a traditional
wife yeah so
why would the Korean not give you a
traditional life because for example at
the I want a
wife who's going to
look after the kids who's going to be
looking at the building up nurturing the
Next Generation which is my children and
when I come home from work I would like
some food on the table
um and many other aspects to be honest
so when she does that she's not going to
be able to do that so if I'm doing my as
a traditional man if I'm doing my part
I'm not going to be seeing that from the
other side because I'm going to have to
come home and she's like oh did you make
food no I did not make food yeah so yeah
sorry yeah exactly because I don't want
to hear that yeah so the thing is here
and this is why a lot of people are
making a lot of mistakes here sisters
maybe you can add on to this here
because you guys didn't really answer it
thank you very much that's because the
question was no let me let me let me
answer my answer look it's very
I've got what you've implied yeah after
some heavy kind of looking into what
you're saying if a person is career
implied like you're implying yeah a
career means that there's a ladder yeah
and there's a beginning and there's an
end so if you're going up the Korea
ladder that means you're going to have
to make certain choices you're going to
have to adopt certain characteristics
and certain traits and those traits tend
to be masculine yeah because
the other traits may not necessarily
work you do have to be stoic you do have
to be assertive you do have to be
tolerant you do need to have a thick
skin stuff that is typically not
associated with women so if that person
now is coming into your life
and you depends what sort of man you are
are you a man that is typically regarded
as a high value man or are you somebody
that's not necessarily a high value man
if they are looking for a high value man
because again
a woman who is in a certain position in
her career she typically wants to marry
someone that's at least equal to her if
not higher so now if she wants a higher
level man that higher higher level man
does he want to come home to somebody
that does have masculine traits and the
question for me would rather the answer
from me would be no if I'm coming home I
don't want to be having debates with
somebody over trivial and small things I
don't want somebody because a man
doesn't want to marry a man well I mean
yeah
in the sense that a man doesn't want to
marry somebody that's also masculine a
female tends not to she tends not to
also want to marry somebody that's also
feminine as well Opposites Attract on on
average kind of thing so bearing that in
mind as a career orientated woman with
the kind of traits that comes with being
in a career I would avoid that
so to answer your question
um I'm gonna break it down a little just
so people don't misunderstand you
um can a sister have a career yes she
can
um we're not saying that
it's a problem for a sister to have a
career haven't said that yet either
do I prefer a sister who is more focused
on a career as opposed to raising a
family and having traditional house
roles I would not want that okay because
it's my job to provide right factors out
of the picture you know just at times
that needs to fluctuate but no I would
not want you to focus um sorry career
oriented woman same
so I think we need to look at what is
causing this to happen right and it's
interesting because you're talking about
like Opposites Attract masculine women
feminist men I actually like when you
see these kind of like celebrity couples
where the woman is like this Powerhouse
boss babe whatever her husband tends to
be quite submissive and well he has no
choice I mean I don't know whether it's
that men have kind of like regressed
into this sort of like fetile sort of
like okay I'll listen to you kind of
like position right but that's the only
way that I've seen it work because then
there's no Clash for power he submits
and understands that his wife is the
boss and he's happy to just you know
Trot along and like spend her money and
and do whatever it's kind of this weird
flip and reverse that's happened it's a
disaster but we need to look at why is
this happening right and and that's
this whole kind of especially in the 90s
there was this massive push with like
shows like sex in the city and things
like that right where they kind of
glamified this life of being 40 and
never married and never had kids and
just working and like living your best
life and traveling and stuff and I
actually
um I was listening to a a a class I've
been taking called white school which I
think everybody should take ay school
before they get married or even after
they get married
um and she was talking about how the
lady who actually wrote the books for
sex in the city
um you know pushed this lifestyle on
women for decades and later went back oh
yeah what's her name she's a feminist I
know I was reading the feminist actually
she's turned back and said she's in her
you know 40s or whatever now and she
hates her life she's divorced and single
and and she's like I've spent my whole
life pushing this and it's not I wish I
chased a career I'm lonely I wish I had
children now that I'm divorced and alone
and I'm in my like late life Wow and and
this is what's been fed to society that
you can be single and free and travel
and hang out with your girls and live
this amazing life but the reality is
women
have an expiration date in terms of
having a family Mendo you guys could be
70 and birth a new family if you wanted
to don't know why you would but if you
did you could do that but as women we
have a limited time frame
um I think it's like 28 or 36 or
something like that anywhere from 18 to
about 28. yeah so we only have this
window and when it passes that's it
you're either gonna adopt in your 50s by
yourself don't go you're talking about
baby oh either whatever you please you
know nowadays there's a market for
everything yeah literally there's cuts
and dogs you could adopt a microwave and
that could be your baby now you know who
knows but they're getting to this point
where they dreamed of this life and it
doesn't fulfill you in the end because
as human beings Allah created us that we
are meant to find our other half we're
meant to build our little Community
inside our home and this is what brings
us peace and this is what looks after us
when we're old Allah says like they
looked after you and you look after them
you know when they're when they're old
and that's what you need you need that
care and love and and companionship in
your age and so they've been brainwashed
to think that that's not what you need
and you can attain whatever you want
anyway but it's just not the reality of
it okay interesting Imani analysis of
female
um so I think it's interesting the way
that you were talking about the traits
that come with somebody who's uh
climbing a career ladder and I think
this is very very true however I would
probably just ask a question it's not
like to trip you up on anything it's
just a question to delve into this more
so what would you suggest for somebody
who is not married has no male to look
after them has to financially provide
for herself has to therefore get a job
has to claim some sort of ladder so that
she's not depreciating in terms of her
finances because we live in an
inflationary world
um
and then wants to get married so me
basically I that's me so exactly so I've
had no choice but to work but to
um you know create my own small business
which I'm very proud of I'm not a boss
babe I don't claim to be anything like
that
oh it's Heston Learning Center it's a
tuition Center for Children and I also
teach uh children and women's Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu as well so yeah the thing that
I would ask is that like I'm really
looking forward to getting married so
inshallah when I do get married I know
that I want to embody the traits that
are feminine I don't want to embody the
traits that I've been forced to embody
because it is being forced to embody
them I've had no choice so I can't wait
until I don't have to do that anymore
and I can say that I really cannot wait
but
um I've understood your point I've
understood yeah but what would you what
would you what would I suggestion okay
but for the 11 years that I've been
Muslim trying to get married not being
able to get married been actively
pursuing it what would you have
suggested a woman like that does stuff
no
um
so it depends if a woman has been in a
career in which she's a secretary she's
around other men she's in a power driven
Corporation in which she is trying to go
up it's it's obvious to a typical person
what that entails however if you're a
nurse yeah however if you're a primary
school teacher I mean I would say I mean
the statistic is like over 80 of the
primary profession are of females so
there are certain careers that is more
palatable it's more digestible for for a
man that's seeking you as a potential
spouse that they can ascertain from your
career choice that this is somebody that
most likely has still retained their
feminine traits okay however if you're
there kind of wrestling and is
professional and this and that again a
man he's he's going to be thinking whoa
like I think a secure man can handle
that yeah I I wouldn't say yes
I'm sorry I just had to say something
for me yeah it's it's not I was just
going to say that like I don't think at
least I've never I don't know if
Brothers do this I don't know if when
brothers are going into marriage they're
like oh she has a career uh she can't be
feminine exactly I don't think people
yeah I don't think men necessarily think
like that but nor are we having a
discussion that entails sisters can't
have a career we're not we're having a
discussion for during marriage but it is
coming across that way I'm listening to
you guys yeah so just clarifying
how much did you have though it's good
you have and you're more than welcome to
do so hold up hold up okay if it's
coming across like that we need to make
clarification straight to the camera we
do not mean that so let's put our game
was very important okay I want to say no
no they don't do they listen to me oh
misogynistic man here yeah uh just to
clarify we are not seeing like for
example my wife had a career she had and
no actually she actually wanted to
pursue it but the thing is we had kids
and while she's she's you know she's a
housewife she's totally happy about here
so the thing is though I'm not saying I
didn't come and say oh my gosh you have
this career I'm not going to marry I
never even had that thought process but
I would ask do you once we get married
do you want to continue it we had that
discussion that's very important so
we're not seeing Korea red flag not
feminine we're not saying that you can
have a career but I think we clarified
that that there are certain yeah just
just always clarify that we not
misunderstood so because we don't want
to make you feel as if it's like what
we're seeing is though at the end of the
day we want to come home to a
traditional wife career-wide that's why
I believe the solution to this why don't
we talk about the solutions last year
that's why I believe feminism has made
the roads kind of reversed in this
context where when you are at your Prime
so the sisters your Prime is 18 to 28
you are at your Prime you are the most
beautiful you are men want to marry you
and women are born with value the best
thing to do I would personally say
sisters is you get married very young
have your kids by the time you're about
30 31 these kids have grown up you you
and your husband uh subhanallah like
you're in your 30s whatever it may be
then get a career we do it the opposite
way first let's get Korea boss babe no
no and then at the age of 30 oh my gosh
my time's running out like that okay
there's a difference the difference the
difference is there's a difference
between Career and a job yeah Korea is
something that's long-term job is
something that's temporary in fact when
people do get career breaks as well yes
but that's why I'm saying I'm
distinguishing between the two let's
just say somebody's got marriage and you
know that your wife is going to be home
you're going to be at work she's going
to be by herself again that's why but
again you're boxing even men in women's
roles which I think now it's not that
box as you're making it even when you're
saying traditional men what is a
traditional man a traditional man also
can help to cook and have those skills a
traditional man can actually help his
wife if the kids are you know
Troublesome and they can say okay I'm
doing the the the whatever the dinner
the dishes whatever there's nothing
wrong can or should I said Can and they
should have the skills to do it when
they go to university they're not going
to have their mummies or even her wife
to even look after them so it's good for
them to have those skills question
though questions I have a question for
her I have a question for her whose main
priority role is that in a relationship
the man or the woman if we are the
children and of course the main priority
what is what is the situation in the
house is it would be nice for a woman to
take on that responsibility but
naturally biologically absolutely who is
better equipped for that role actually
nowadays you you could argue either or
because I know someone breastfeed
when you asked me about one thing and
that's it she said biology I said
biologically he was more equipped I
allowed to take care of the kids who has
been given that role by Allah absolutely
but there are a lot of unfortunately
circumstance that I see where the women
are not doing that even if it's
biologically in that but the man is
providing there's a lot of homes that
are broken where the women you know at
the end of the day they're not able to
do that and a man can't take that role
what do you mean why they're not able to
give like an example like what do you
well if there's mental health issues for
the for the wife for example okay so I
know it's exceptional but it's happening
more and more and the statistics are
higher I deal with that you know in a
very everyday issue so what I'm trying
to say is you know when you say
traditional man yes it is the way it
should be nice in that way but you know
we're not living in those sort of
circumstances anymore where at the end
of the day a man has to only work and
provide the women can contribute and to
have a career does not take away her
femininity even if you're working in
those High sort of like profile
businesses or careers or whatever that's
maybe masculine energy and she doesn't
have to bring that masculine energy to
find masculine energy masculine energy
is having that leadership role having
that argumentative sort of
characteristics
well it's called Energy that's what it
is because it def it differentiates
between her being where's that energy
coming from
um the energy is coming from the fact
that she has to be in a particular
Persona yeah
uh maybe be at work right
Persona and characteristics yeah and it
doesn't mean that she can't be both it
doesn't mean if she works in that
particular way that she can't also be
feminine and also bring a sort of like a
different sort of stance so you're
saying she needs to have two
contradictory characteristics
you ask me too much no but you can we do
that all the time we do that when we're
at home we are certain characters at
home and when we go to work we're
different counts U.S that's where mental
health problems come from no absolutely
not yeah it's called split personalities
exactly is if they know how to go home
and have respect to their husbands
exactly they won't act like that they
won't take on those trains what if she's
in a position where she loses that
respect maybe
it can get hard I get what you're saying
that when you're trying to enmesh the
two so much all the time it can become
bubbling I understand that but I also
agree with the fact that no actually if
you are for whatever reason as a woman
in a as you say non-idealistic situation
to you you've fallen into a career
whatever as long as you have respect for
your husband you still have the ability
to go home and not act like boss baby or
whatever he can be the man so on the one
hand you have a biological inclination
yeah and for you to go towards your
biological inclination and of course
societal inclination that's ideal and
let's cumbersome on you when you start
putting something that's against your
biology and against sociology and you're
trying to measure the team together
sorry how is it against it because women
are we can be more than one sort of
trait and characteristic yeah you can
get the mental health issues no who says
that yeah
no if they're saying it they're not
coming from a professional point of view
these are peer review journals no even
still I'm doing research
no these these these research that is
happening right now they're very very
you know very very limited even in its
research right when it comes to factors
of mental health it is not what you're
just saying that it is trust me okay
mental health does not come from only
that it's not it's genetic it's biologic
biology as well as environmental
health there is is not about mental
health let's just make something very
clear it is it is
maybe we went okay but the topic right
now let me just bring it back into the
topic here it's about do men want a
career orientated wife yeah I hope that
makes sense so so let me make it very
clear yeah look I'm a man let me ask you
ask you one by one when it comes to this
issue I have a concern where if my wife
is the obviously a provider but if she's
working I let me I've made this very
clear before if my wife was a
multi-millionaire I would tell you I'm
not paying for the rent you're not
paying for the shopping you're not
paying for the petrol you're not paying
for the council tax you're not paying
for electric gas none of it no money
that's your money enjoy it do every lack
of the year but you are not doing that
because why because at the end of the
day we agreed in our other episode that
sisters can say stuff that can slice you
up into pieces if she comes on one day
and goes well guess who contributes it
might be unintentional it might be she
doesn't mean it but for a man is that
somebody joked you you're gonna joke it
means you understand you yeah by the way
so to us it's like words like with us
we're physically strong women are
mentally more stronger than us I believe
here that's why you guys end up getting
over break breakups easier than men yeah
we suffer and we have like suicide race
and all and other kind of stuff yeah yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes 100 it's
significant there's no side I'm talking
about the breakups no even the breakups
we get hurt at the very beginning yes
but on the long run long term yes but we
suffer you haven't seen that many where
the guys break up and he's like and the
girl's like Ugh and then it's like three
months later he's crippled and she's
like oh A New Beginning yeah so you guys
are why because you can go to your
girlfriends and be like hey you know you
can start crying if I go to my friend
and cry he'll give me one uppercut yeah
yeah why are you crying for oh sorry
yeah we have to bottle up this is as men
we have this woman you can express it
sometimes you know it's kind of up in
the situation in my life when I'm in
difficulty even crying to Allah it was
like wow this is some powerful stuff man
crying to your lord yeah it's powerful
whatever crying for my wife very rarely
very rarely that's not a different topic
but the point we're seeing is this men
in general do not want a wife who is
career orientated on the long run that's
why I said what I said in the beginning
if at a young age when they're 18 years
old if they get if for example they go
to UNI they want to be a teacher a
doctor whatever good you've got the
qualifications good marry now
get have kids have a family this is your
Peak after that when your kids grow up
to an age you want to go into your
career that's fine but not at the cost
of your traditional husband coming home
and
um there's no food because he's doing
this I don't think it's about food I
think it's more about wearing the choose
it's more about reading the children and
I agree with you because I know a lot of
career women that actually would choose
second time round not to be working when
their children are at a certain age but
it doesn't mean that they're not doctors
and dentists and that's mostly what I'm
surrounded with women who are Muslim
especially from the Iraqi communities
you know who are in that who are both
working as professional in that high
level right and they are managing a
family a home and the husband they are
there no but there's a real a huge group
of them there is not exceptional that's
what I'm trying to say I'm around that
community care for something
men and women we think very differently
so let's just make sure that we're
understanding what the other is saying
before we before we take conversations
to different directions I don't have a
problem and I have a question for you at
the end of this I don't have a problem
with my wife working
what do I mean by this if she sorry let
me rephrase that I don't have a problem
with my wife making her own money okay
if she makes more than me all right cool
like you said I don't want you paying
for this this is my job I'm maintaining
I'm providing inshallah and rent is mine
grocery is mine like whatever it is that
needs to be fulfilled I'm taking care of
that do you make your own money all
right cool you make your own money the
conversation of whether or not I want my
wife to work that will take uh place
before the marriage actually even
happens right but I don't I don't have
an issue with my wife making money or
having her own money obviously or her
making more money than me my question to
you is
would you be okay let's just say one day
your wife says I want to work
what's your response to that very simple
for example if we've got a child if we
also have another child argument's sake
or another child yeah the question is
very simple yes my what's gonna happen
to my childhood question should be why
isn't it no no no of course it's why why
but the reason why they want to do it is
because of this feministic
indoctrination of no it comes from that
because what it is is you know you know
where the custom sister is the
vilification of being a mother oh you're
at home mother okay no you're just
outside
and let me tell you something yeah it
comes from the friends that we were
talking about earlier uh it comes from
society yeah I know but when you've got
them a group of friends as as a female
you'll you'll say to them for example
I've just got married unity and all of
that and you've gone through the anime
all the rest of it and you've got a kid
right and you say oh I'm gonna stay home
for the kid they're gonna say You're
really gonna stay home exactly yeah and
then that what that does inside of you
is you're gonna say I shouldn't be
settling for that no exactly no this is
the issue with vilifying we're vilifying
being a mother why can't my wife have a
that's amazing I mean it's an amazing
thing why can't she be a housewife well
the moment you say this oh my gosh is
that all you're doing and these same
girls who are saying this who are then
end up in their 30s not married yet not
married and they're realizing that the
likelihood of them um conceiving is
drastically dropping they are getting
I'm not going to say uglier but you know
you know their beauty is diminishing
slowly and the yeah I don't use the
shelf life but you know their peak time
is on its way out the other one I'm
trying to find different ways if you can
help me the point is this then they hit
a rock wall and guess what happens all
those standards boom what happens making
a lot of assumptions I really do I think
we're making a lot of assumptions I
think we're making a lot of assumptions
I think it's really really really
offensive to turn around and say that
every single woman Muslim women let's
talk about Muslim women first yeah every
single Muslim women who is I'm not
married yet but who is married and has
decided that they want a job is doing it
for that reason so personally in my
circle of friends and this is amongst
practicing sisters not so practicing
sisters
um anybody who is married has a good
husband he earns not even loads of money
but just enough to pay for everything
they need she doesn't want to work she's
happy bro she is happy she does not want
to work she is cool if she has worked
very very hard for her career she's a
doctor dentist whatever she may keep
some sort of
um active you know she may be active in
the community so she may write for
journals she may um appear at certain
events she made you some odd local work
if you know if needed but she will
happily step back from whatever career
she's in if she is being provided for if
her children are being provided for yeah
but what I'm saying is it that's why
it's a very dangerous statement to turn
around and say that the women in our
community who are doing that are doing
it for some kind of status or whatever
the only I can tell you that
categorically the only women out of my
friends who I've seen get a job after
getting married
um a woman whose husbands were not
providing they were literally working
part-time running running home to their
mum's house for a week not paying the
bill she's getting everything's in her
name because for whatever financial
reasons he's put everything in her name
you know so she's liable for the rent
she has no choice she's like you know I
have no I have to go with my sister
again we need to disclaim this one
second disclaimer number one firstly we
are not talking about those women
we're not talking about factors
please we're talking about women who are
like Korea before motherhood career
before I don't think most women said
dude
the things
I wish everybody was like you the point
is they're not so that's what we're
saying is you said you were seeking
marriage for about 11 years you were
seek it you're not amongst them we're
talking about people girls who are in
touch with saying no to marriage I'm
going to be a boss baby career once they
reach first Islam debt is establishing a
Masjid and a community center if you
donate to build this Masjid Allah will
inshallah build the house for you in
Jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this Masjid
every child that memorized the Quran you
will inshallah share in that reward
donate now guys and do not delay then
they realize oh time out oh my gosh I'm
not as a man you because we do not want
I do not care if my wife was a Dustbin
collector I don't care your career means
nothing to me so the thing is I would
choose a based on many factors as men we
do so what we're seeing is a lot of
girls we're not talking about what
you're talking about we're talking about
this set of girls yes these boss babes
these feminists let me ask the questions
come from where do you think they come
from
the industry your point it's the way
it's the way we illustrate your point
okay it's the wrong conversation where
does it come from well when I go to
Speakers Corner and I have a sister
um I mean where do you think her story
comes from from being that is that one
she's mentioned something about her
Father which I do not know yet but the
point is this feminism is infiltrating
our houses we see this yeah so what I'm
saying is why does my wife or anyone
else's wife have to feel that being a
housewife is I'm not doing nothing in my
life no I think they're just scared of
the what's a factor as well why is my
wife or anybody's wife feeling like I'm
just a housewife and I and I have to
reassurance go are you mad this is the
most amazing thing what I'm saying my
wife says or not I'm saying I hear these
stories but the point is our sisters are
being felt as I'm not doing nothing with
my life you are doing the most amazing
thing a woman could ever do you're
nurturing the Next Generation I'm doing
my bit you're doing a bit don't let
these boss baby feminist radicals make
you feel that what you're doing is
rubbish you're our child Brother come on
while lies I deep to me that's what
we're talking about but even regardless
I really think that those stories that
they are telling themselves come from
the failed stories that are around us
even if you don't want to address it
right that's where they're coming about
men no I'm talking about the women that
want to be boss babies is because they
want to secure they want to secure
themselves so that if they are innocent
marriage their husbands can't provide
all their husbands leave them or the
fact that you know their husbands pass
away or there's an accident they are
able to take care this is valid this is
valid that's valid we're we're not
discussing factors factors are being
brought up we're not talking about a
situation of his sister you know who's
married and her husband's not provided I
don't think most women want to be those
boss babes that you're describing of
course of course they don't they only
might say it on time because they're not
getting the husband that's not even the
conversation
what you're saying you don't want to get
into factors but I'm just saying that
those are important because here we're
talking about boss babes sorry let me
just let me just address these two
sisters and what they're actually
talking about because this is actually a
toxic mentality that us women are going
into marriages with right so as human
beings we focus on what can harm us it's
our natural instinct to protect us
against danger right so we have this
sister that I knew back in school who
got married her husband beat her she
ended up in a home whatever you know and
we hear these stories and we're like
just in case I get married and my
husband beats me I gotta have a backup
plan I gotta have an exit strategy you
cannot enter a marriage with the fear of
Allah in your heart and say I'm going to
go into this marriage preparing to leave
it if you go into a marriage preparing
to leave it you haven't even entered
that marriage and so we're entering
these marriages saying I need a job I
need a career I need to fall back he's
not going to pay for this he's going to
leave me he's gonna cheat on me he's
gonna whatever why are we TR like losing
our trust in Allah that we are our
every man is going out and cheating
I have to be trusty Allah says be trust
even if it's against yourself yeah look
it can be that men are also one of the
factors maybe that is causing our sister
to do that but what's happening is it's
becoming as if they say a viral
infection no a lot of men provide other
men that don't are they evil of course
yeah but Ali Ali who's who's picking
those men though
well they don't always show up okay
those men yes it's true yeah and you're
making bad decisions
that you're putting mothers and wives on
right now it's beautiful by the way the
way that you're explaining this role
this is not how a lot of men explain the
role even Muslim men they will be the
first ones to put their wife down
exactly and do nothing there's a lot of
men that don't want that okay okay
what we're seeing is this year we're
seeing that these men look at the end of
the day we should be the ones that are
encouraging our wives okay 100 I
understand if a woman is like you know
what she's had a father who used to be
up the mom and she saw this insecurity
understand it can happen and she's like
I have to you know prepare have a career
that's fine you can go do a degree but
but
then say you know what no I'm in such
fear that I'm going to work I'm going to
hold on a second I want you to be a
traditional wife and we need to stay at
home look after our kids I will provide
I have no problem now when you come and
move boss people me we're talking about
those kind of a woman please put them
into that category not those we're
talking about boss babes feminist
radical feminists extremists we'll call
them terrorists if you like here these
these kind here call them that these
women were talking about who are going
like no I don't need to like you're
talking about they're pretending they're
pretending I think they pretend yes it
can it can be but the thing is it's
coming at the cost our sisters it's been
infiltrating their mind they don't want
to be a mother or a wife because it's
being vilified when it comes to issue of
uh job um gender roles the thing is this
would I Hoover the house yes wash the
dishes yes
um I don't know whatever you want okay
no no no no let me finish yeah I will do
that but if I want to
yeah I will do that if I want to know
what is if I want to meet if I come home
if you need to and we've got two kids
argument's sake yeah and I look at my
wife she is exhausted finished products
I've been working yeah I've been working
yeah the thing is because we don't see
what dads do yeah I've been working yeah
and I come home and I look and I'm like
subhanallah she's the food is ready you
know what I will wash the dishes no
problem it's caring we're not animals
I'm not going to be like I'm a
traditional man you're a traditional
woman shut up come and do this and wash
my feet after no I'm gonna be like hold
on a second she looks exhausted you've
made the food are you doing sit down no
problem my discretion not by the way
you're gonna if a woman came to me and
said I'm gonna wash dishes I said
wash dishes psychology behind the boss
babe is because they're just trying to
fit into their Narrative of where they
are right now and to make it look okay
but if they were given the opportunity
to be with somebody who fits or match
them or whatever it is that was they
would actually take their opportunity a
lot of women will actually take that but
it's just that they're not in that role
so they're just doing it if there is a
man a real man yeah yeah which doesn't
existence yeah yeah and he's like you
know what I will provide I will protect
good man because the studies show that
James book miseducation woman that woman
tend to be they want to be at home what
life is showing they said we don't want
to work exactly
I think our sisters are saying is this
Brothers yeah where are they if there's
real men yeah we don't mind being
traditional wise is that correct yep are
you sure about it precisely could I just
interject
just also slightly more than that
because I feel having a career is also
good for you because we all have skills
we all have something to you know give
towards and if you're doing it no but
you're also you're also minimizing what
women should and shouldn't do as a
career yeah
Ali I think you're going to like the
extreme on this right so where you you
need to balance in life okay because
you're like oh you can only do these
things that at home and I don't think
that's correct what I thought wait wait
what I think what I think is correct is
that we know our roles we know our
duties given to us by Allah and those
are our priorities so if your husband
can provide for you your first priority
is the home yes you can't go out and get
a career and a job and be like oh well
now you're going to split the work 50 50
with me at home because it's not his
responsibility Allah has told him you
must provide for your family and you are
you are hindering him from doing that
but if your life balances that you can
work and still take care of the home
that's your duty to take on both roles
and then that's your responsibility you
can't come on be like oh I'm so tired
from working all day can you pick up my
slack because you're doing something
that's optional whereas he's doing
something that is mandatory upon Him by
Allah commanded by Allah and so it comes
with balance it doesn't matter what job
she's doing that's don't say painting or
sewing I know but you're like you can
only do things from home that's not true
but it's your responsibility as a woman
prioritize the duties that Allah has
given you if you so choose with your
husband to do that you don't have to do
one specific career it has two sister if
she's the doctor and she's a shift of 18
hours
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna marry a
doctor whose uncle and I come home she's
more exhausted than me yeah but doctors
don't have to be that they could she
could leave that and work in a clinic on
the weekends there's many different
things
very simple as men in online medic this
has become yeah
online medical no problem six hours a
day how many hours a day give me hours a
day
household is her business okay okay she
should run that like her business
therefore she wants to take on
additional work like the sister just
said she would need to manage that time
it might be one hour if that's all she
can have I have a computer
why is she doing this I don't know I'm
not her but yeah
she has a drive to serve she's qualified
she's skilled she might want
one second why do she because she's
already finished we have a meaning in
life each one of us and a purpose
even our communities right and if we
have a skill to serve others it's also
part of it it's not just for the men to
go outside okay I'm sorry brother
zeeshan you can't answer why women want
this we can answer so I myself have been
working in film since I was 16 years old
I'll love it it's my passion it's my joy
yes I love being a mother yes I love
being at home and I love feeding my
family but I love it if I want to do a
short film Project here that works
within my daughter's schedule and it
works with my life cool I can do that
because it makes me happy and as women
we can do things that make us happy yeah
I wasn't going to say that though
is seven we're talking about different
Dynamics
look if you have a child you're not
going to be able to do no movies you're
not going to be able to do it since I
love you operation is impossible what
we're seeing is the following yeah it's
impossible what we're saying is you said
oh no but we can offer Society more okay
Society man save yourself and your
family from the fire why can't you why
is it that my husband being a house wife
a mother why is this not a success that
is the problem we're talking about do
you think that at least I didn't decide
it's also having that success is also in
the house could you actually providing
in the house you're setting sort of
standards in the house you will not want
to go and be something else I'm saying
but humans can are able to do that they
may not be able to do it every single
day for six seven ten years maybe
they'll have breaks like you said that's
right that's what it is success is not
the same as happiness right exactly
additional happiness that is like saying
okay because your duty is to go out and
provide you're not allowed to do
anything else other than go out and
provide nothing else nothing for fun
nothing at all I tell my wife here she's
a she's a teacher you can do as long as
you're doing that you can do other
things too
I tell my wife she's got a she's a
t-shirt yeah okay I tell her if our kids
grow up you want to go back to
teaching.com
at as long as it doesn't violate my
rights yes okay so what I'm saying is
now if you want to be you know juggling
two things yeah and as long as it
doesn't for example the husband comes
home oh so sorry we're trying to learn
here and you know it's for the yeah if
if food or if he wants intimacy oh I'm
tired you're finally to my rights no you
are my little my right now because
they've said multiple times that if you
can manage the time effectively whereby
your obligations and duties
exactly if your obligations and Duties
are never ever ever claimized as a woman
so that doesn't happen Okay okay you
know what you know what's gonna happen
eventually okay look you know what
that's a superwoman that's super
Superman let's call it super moon if she
can do that all good one but I know at
one place it's gonna crack I can't
manage both and what's gonna happen it's
gonna come at the cost of my rights
being violated so we're just seeing this
and this stems from where oh I being a
mother no no I need to do better because
eight minutes and let's talk about after
this brother I'd like to hear whether
the because we've heard how passionate
you are that women can't handle both I'd
like to hear whether the other brothers
think that women could have a small job
on the side with their home
10 minutes but can I just address a
couple points just very quickly The
Nanny comment right you're no longer
bring out the job that's the nanny doing
that because you're spending what two
three hours with a kid then they're
going to sleep then you go back to the
nanny so you want to think about Karen
you know at the end of the day
um there may be moments not the whole
time that's not enough
is the priority isn't the career but but
the priority let me carry on that okay
right so that's the only comment I've
I've addressed that uh number two we
said
um that uh oh if if the mother's tired
and then somebody said that they
wouldn't do the dishes for example right
um the prophet saws used to help
um
like sometimes in the house right you'd
come in he'd help her with the with the
um with the cooking and whatnot in fact
she she came with had even said that he
would
yeah oh right so he he'd never with the
with the jobs in the house right and
he'd come in he'd kiss her and he says
uh more the rest of it and they need
help her in the house right we're not
saying if you know if you're tired and
there's too much we wouldn't help at all
what we're saying is you're going to
enjoy up eight ten hours right and with
transport and all the rest of it right
eight ten hours and then you're coming
hours though who says that well you get
eight hour jobs right
right and anyway anyway let me just
right so so you go to drop six hours a
day six hours a day yeah why even that
much
for a woman for for a woman is career
driven she's gonna try and go for a
full-time job if she's going to a
full-time job the issue is that she's
gonna come home she's tired right she's
going to call him she's tired she can't
carry on with everything else which is
fine because she's human we're saying
she's human what you're doing is you're
saying no she can go to a full-time job
this is what the feminists do they come
in and they say no she can I'm not
feminine let me just let me just let me
just she comes in and she says hey I've
got a full-time job right and I'm
spending this amount of hours working
and I'm getting this this income
whatever
but I've got two kids okay the issue
here is now she's gonna come home the
guys because because of cultural social
norms whatever you want to call it the
guy is going to say right well the house
is not done she's now going to go
through the mental process of Rights so
I've just worked eight hours six hours
two hours we agree and now and now I've
got eight hours to work out at the house
she's gonna spend no time with a kid no
time with her husband by the time you
spend time with her husband she's
sleeping no let me let me wrap up real
quickly when you've when you're career
driven the issue is you don't spend time
with a kid so the kids being brought up
by what media Nanny right you do you you
can't 100 make sure the nanny's doing
the right thing right whatever else
right and number two you're not spending
time with the husband you're violating
his rights so now he's gonna Step Into
Your Role which
um it makes a man more effeminate right
and then make sure you're more masculine
because you need to compensate so the
issue here is you're like are the career
character agree when where where coming
from the angle of you don't need it
because we're trying to provide for you
well let's see if we can find this is
why this is why in the very very last
Point very last point this is why
Allah and the prophet saws said the
money of the woman is hers you don't
touch it that it's got nothing to do
with you that's why for example women
get less inherited because it's all
theirs they do whatever they want with
it therefore therefore I mean I agree
with everything that you're saying
there's nothing that you said which
we've disagreed with not me anyway and
um we're coming back around to the same
thing again which is that okay so there
is a distinct difference between a few
different things that I think we've
covered so there's career so a woman
having a career that's somebody who you
said is climbing a ladder it's a there's
an obvious uh progression that's going
on there and it's an obvious
um orientation that they have yeah it's
something they're very focused on it's a
career then a woman could have a job
just a job something that makes you
money yeah yeah for whatever reason she
might need that
then you have a third scenario which is
what you were talking about which is
where we're not equating success with
happiness so for example a man can go
and provide for you he can go and do all
of those things you can be happy with
that you don't need to prove anything
you're happy with your role as well but
maybe you want a hobby this hobby
happens to make you money that's fine we
didn't say that what we're saying is
when it starts to become a detriment to
the home but it works that's what I mean
but that's what I mean exactly as long
as it doesn't then it's not an issue is
it okay guys look this can go forever
we're gonna put probably part two yeah
we shouldn't leave that house I don't
understand what the point was
what was the like the point of what what
was being said that success is no is
known as happiness this is what she was
trying to say which is that okay we're
talking about um
where you guys are explaining these
women who want to work right you're
talking about how can they not see what
they have already as success yeah and
it's like no she completely thinks
that's raising a family she is
completely happy and feeling successful
with her daughter
but she wants to go and make a film
because that's her passion and she's
like you know what this is this is not
going to interfere about if it was she
wouldn't do it all right so so yeah so
here we're talking about passions but
when it comes to a man exercising his
passions no he needs to control himself
so when it comes what do you mean if I
can just if I can just finish my point
because it was in the previous episode
oh when it comes to you know having
another wife or fulfilling men need to
control themselves men need to be like
this
I don't think I don't think the reason
I'm saying I don't think it's extreme if
the argument no no I'm not saying no no
no
because on the one hand yeah on the one
hand it's a passion like I have a
passion to do a job yeah you want to do
something thing so on the one hand we're
told to kind of control certain things
on the other hand we're saying no no
over here it's natural and we should do
it but islamically the community is
always put above the individual and here
we've been talking a lot about well
individually I might want to do this
and I might want to do that but if we
actually look at the community that
we're actually living in we've admitted
that social media is very powerful we've
admitted that films and movies are very
powerful where we uh we hopefully admit
that the education system is
it's it's like a colonized curriculum
injected with LGBT and all of this so we
are now having to undo all of this how
is this going to happen when we're not
at home we're doing other stuff I think
to understand on a macro level this is
what's happening to the children this is
the award that's happening to the
marital relationship priority again I'm
I haven't completed the point that I'm
saying priority should be going to
maintaining the marriage because of the
forces that are at Play Breaking the
couples apart it should be given to the
kids because of the amount of
indoctrination they need your time they
need the mother and the father no tanani
not a grandmother not a grandfather they
need a mother and the father because the
the child the the person that treats the
child the best is typically the mother
and the father they cannot get that love
from an uncle or not I wish I could find
men that actually thought like that
because to be honest the majority of men
want women to work today right
yeah so so then we we look okay if uh
when you get married as a man again
we're talking about typically speaking a
man knows that his wife's gonna be at
home at the moment she doesn't have
children so now you need to discuss how
she's going to stay occupied and what
she's going to be able to do now does
she have hobbies yeah can you help her
facilitate her Hobbies can she do
certain our activities now why is this
why is the only way for you to express
yourself and do certain things through
career that's not the only way first
thing could be through Hobbies it could
be through dawah it could be through
education and stuff like that there's
ways of building yourself and building
other characteristics that will be
conducive to the marriage not
or homeschooling there are other things
that that can actually be searched no
I've got as much time as I want
so so these things what I'm saying is
look rather than saying oh I'm gonna
swipe left I'm gonna swipe right or he
doesn't do this and he looks boring and
hear this and he that the thing is we
need to be more particular with our
questions our criteria taking our
woolies seriously and really kind of
investigating the individual that we're
getting married to if you're going to
get married to this person and end up
working and that person's not going to
find you attractive and this and that is
it can cause detriment and issues
inshallah uh so if you guys enjoyed
inshallah these discussions are here to
just learn from each other inshallah
obviously it's it's a discussion I don't
want a piece of love my boy needs to go
so we need to make sure okay different
problem sisters from the bitter truth we
have discussions what do you think do
you agree do you disagree maybe you can
be on the panel next time inshallah till
next time from the bitty truth show with
our Dear honorable sisters and our
brothers who have contribute foreign
[Music]
house in Jannah on that day where Allah
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atom weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and what a
lucky person which righteous person
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do you allowed people to pray
you built a Masjid I never had the money
to build a master to Allah you helped
you gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you've built it
don't let it now guys and do not delay
and share the video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]